Yo hago dos cosas, diseño computadora móviles y estudio cerebros.
Y la charla de hoy se trata de cerebros y,
¡Si! En algún lugar tengo un fan de cerebros.
(Risas)
Voy a, si me pueden poner la primera diapositiva,
y verán el titulo de mi platica y mis dos afiliaciones.
Así que de lo que voy a hablar, es el porqué no tenemos una buena teoría acerca del cerebro,
porque es importante que desarrollemos una y qué podemos hacer al respecto.
Intentaré hacer eso en 20 minutos. Tengo dos afiliaciones.
La mayoría de ustedes me conocen por mis días de Palm y Handspring
pero también administro un instituto de investigación científica sin fines de lucro.
llamado el Instituto Redwood de Neurociencia en Menlo Park,
y estudiamos neurociencia teórica,
y estudiamos como funciona la neo-corteza.
Voy a hablar acerca de todo eso.
Tengo sólo una diapositiva sobre mi otra vida, las computadoras, y es ésta.
Estos son algunos de los productos que desarrollé en los últimos 20 años,
empezando desde la muy original laptop hasta algunas de las primeras computadoras de panel.
y así sucesivamente, hasta llegar recientemente al Treo.
y continuamos haciendo ésto.
Y he hecho ésto porque realmente creo que la computación móvil
es el futuro de la computación personal, y estoy intentando hacer un mundo
un poco mejor, trabajando sobre estas cosas.
Pero esto fue, tengo que admitir, un accidente.
Realmente no quise crear ninguno de estos productos
y muy temprano en mi carrera decidí
que no iba a estar en la industria de la computación.
Y antes de comentarles de todo eso, tengo que decirles
que esta pequeña imagen de graffiti que saqué de la red el otro día.
Estaba buscando una imagen de graffiti, un pequeño lenguaje de entrada de texto,
y encontré el sitio web dedicado a maestros que quieren hacer estos,
texto escrito en la parte superior de sus pizarrones,
y le habían agregado graffiti, y lo lamento.
(Risas)
Así que lo que pasó fue, que cuando era joven y terminé la escuela de ingeniería,
Cornell en el 79, decidí, que trabajaría para Intel.
Yo estaba en la industria de las computadoras y a los tres meses de eso,
me enamoré de otra cosa y dije, "Me equivoque de carrera aquí,"
y me enamoré de los cerebros.
Esto no es un cerebro de verdad. Esto es una imagen de uno en arte lineal.
Pero no recuerdo exactamente como sucedió,
pero tengo un recuerdo, que es bastante fuerte en mi mente.
En septiembre 1979, Scientific American (Revista) publicó
un número de un sólo tema acerca del cerebro. Y fue bastante bueno.
Fue uno de los mejores números publicados. Y escribieron sobre la neurona,
el desarrollo, enfermedad, la visión y todas las cosas
que quisieras saber acerca de los cerebros. Esto fue bastante impresionante.
Podemos tener la impresión de que sabemos mucho acerca del cerebro.
Pero el último articulo de ese numero fue escrito por Francis Crick de la fama ADN.
Hoy es, creo, el 50vo aniversario del descubrimiento del ADN.
El escribió una nota que básicamente decía,
bueno, que esto esta todo muy bien, pero saben que,
no sabemos nada del cerebro£
y nadie tiene idea de como funcionan estas cosas,
así que no crean nada de lo que les digan.
Este es una cita de lo que decía el articulo. Dijo, "Lo que se carece evidentemente"
es un educado caballero Ingles asi que, "Lo que se carece evidentemente
es un extenso marco de refrencia sobre el cual interpretar los diferentes enfoques."
Yo pensé que "marco de referencia" era excelente.
No dijo que no tenemos siquiera una teoría. Dice,
ni siquiera sabemos como empezar a pensar en ello --
ni siquiera tenemos un marco de referencia.
Estamos en los días del pre-paradigma si quieres usar a Thomas Kuhn.
Así que me enamoré de esto y dije mira,
Tenemos todo este conocimiento acerca de cerebros. ¿Qué tan difícil puede ser?
Y esto es algo con lo que podemos trabajar durante mi vida. Sentí que podía hacer una diferencia,
a si que intenté salirme del negocio del computo, y entrar al del cerebro.
Primero, fuí a MIT, el laboratorio de inteligencia artificial estaba ahí,
y dije, bueno, también quiero crear máquinas inteligentes.
pero la manera que quiero hacerlo es estudiando cómo funciona el cerebro.
Ellos dijeron, no tienes que hacer eso.
Sólo vamos a programar computadoras, es todo lo que necesitamos hacer.
Y yo dije, no, realmente deberían estudiar cerebros. ellos dijeron, sabes que,
estas mal. Y le dije no, ustedes están mal, y no me dejaron entrar.
(Risas)
Pero estaba un poco decepcionado -- bastante joven, pero regrese
unos años después en California y fui a Berkeley.
Y dije, llegaré por el lado biológico.
Así que entré - al doctorado en Biofísica, y pensé, bien,
Ya estoy estudiando cerebros, y dije, bien, quiero estudiar teoría.
Y ellos dijeron, oh no, no se puede estudiar teoría de cerebros.
Eso no es algo que se hace. No te dan fondos para hacer eso.
Y como graduado, no puedes hacer eso. Así que dije, rayos.
Estaba muy deprimido. Dije, pero puedo hacer una diferencia en este campo.
Así que lo que hice fue regresar a la industria de las computadoras
y dije, bueno, tendré que trabajar aquí un tiempo, hacer algo.
Eso es cuando diseñe todos esos productos de computadora.
(Risas)
Y dije, quiero hacer esto cuatro años, ganar dinero,
estaba formando una familia y maduraría un poco,
y quizá el negocio de la neurociencia también maduraría un poco.
Bueno, tomó mas de cuatro años. Van como 16 años.
Pero ya lo estoy haciendo, y les voy a platicar al respecto.
Así que ¿Por qué debemos tener una buena teoría cerebral?
Pues hay muchas razones por las que las personas hacen ciencia.
Una es -- la más básica -- es que nos gusta saber las cosas.
Somos curiosos, y salimos a buscar conocimiento, ¿cierto?
¿Por qué estudiamos las hormigas? Pues, porque es interesante.
Quizá aprendamos algo realmente útil al respecto, pero es interesante y fascinante.
Pero a veces, una ciencia tiene otros atributos
que lo hacer verdaderamente interesante.
A veces la ciencia nos dice algo al respecto de nosotros mismos,
nos dice quienes somos.
Rara vez, tu sabes, la evolución hizo esto y Copernico hizo esto,
donde tenemos un nuevo entendimiento de que quienes somos.
Y finalmente, somos nuestros cerebros. Mi cerebro habla a tu cerebro.
Nuestros cuerpos están como pasajeros, pero mi cerebro habla con tu cerebro.
Y si queremos entender quienes somos y como nos sentimos y percibimos,
realmente entenderemos que son los cerebros.
Otra cosa es que a veces la ciencia
lleva a grandes beneficios para la sociedad y tecnología,
o negocios, o lo que sea que salga de ello. Y esta es una de ella también,
porque cuando entendemos como funcionan los cerebros, vamos a poder
construir máquinas inteligentes, y creo que en general eso es algo bueno,
y va a tener beneficios tremendos para la sociedad
como una tecnología fundamental
Entonces ¿Por qué no tenemos una buena teoría de cerebros?
Y las personas llevan 100 años trabajando en ello.
Bueno, primero observemos como es la ciencia normal.
Esto es ciencia normal.
La ciencia normal tiene un buen balance entre la teoría y la experimentación.
Así que los teóricos dicen, buen, yo creo que esto es lo que está sucediendo,
y los experimentales dicen, no, estas mal.
Luego va y viene, sabes?
Esto funciona en la física, en la geología. Pero esto es ciencia normal,
¿Cómo se ve la neurociencia? Así es como se ve la neurociencia.
Tenemos esta montaña de datos, que son anatomía, fisiología y comportamiento.
No puedes imaginarte cuanto detalle tenemos sobre los cerebros.
Hubieron 28,000 personas que atendieron a la conferencia de neurociencia este año,
y cada uno de ellos esta haciendo investigaciones sobre el cerebro.
Son muchos datos. Pero no hay teoría. Hay este cuadro pequeña y débil encima.
Y la teoría no ha jugado un rol significativo en la neurociencia.
Y esto es una lastima. ¿Por qué a sucedido esto?
Si le preguntas a un neurocientífico, ¿Por qué es este estado?
En primera instancia lo admitirán. Pero si les preguntas, dirán,
bueno, hay varias razones por las que no tenemos una buena teoría del cerebro.
Algunas personas dicen, bueno, aun no tenemos suficientes datos,
necesitamos obtener más información, hay todas estas cosas que sabemos.
Bueno, acabo de decirte que hay datos saliendo hasta por las orejas.
Tenemos tanta información que no sabemos ni como empezar a organizarla.
¿De qué nos va a servir mas información?
Quizá tengamos suerte y descubramos alguna solución mágica, pero lo dudo.
Esto es realmente un síntoma del hecho de que no tenemos una teoría.
No necesitamos mas datos -- necesitamos una buena teoría al respecto.
Otra es que a veces las personas dicen, es que, los cerebros son tan complejos,
que tomaría otros 50 años.
Incluso creo que Chris, dijo algo así ayer.
No estoy seguro de lo que dijiste, Chris, pero fue algo como,
bueno, es una de las cosas mas complicadas en el universo. Eso no es verdad.
Tu eres mas complicado que tu cerebro. Tienes un cerebro.
También, aunque el cerbero se ve muy complicado,
las cosas se ven complicadas hasta que las entiendes.
Ese siempre es el caso. Así que todos podemos decir, bueno,
mi neo-corteza, que es la parte del cerebro en la que estoy interesada tiene 30 mil millones de células.
Pero, ¿Sabes qué? Es muy, muy regular.
Es más, parece ser lo mismo repetido una y otra vez.
No es tan complejo como parece. Ese no es el tema.
Algunas personas dicen, los cerebros no pueden entender cerebros.
Se escucha muy Zen. Wow. Tu sabes --
(Risas)
Se escucha bien, pero ¿Por qué? Es decir, ¿Cuál es el caso?
Son sólo un montón de células. Entiendes tu hígado.
También tiene muchas células, ¿Verdad?
Así que, tu sabes, no creo que tenga mucha validez eso.
Finalmente, algunas personas dicen, bueno,
No me siento como un montón de células. Estoy conciente.
Tengo esta experiencia, estoy en el mundo.
No puedo ser sólo un montón de células. Bueno,
las personas antes creían que había una fuerza vital para pode vivir,
y sabemos que eso no es realmente cierto para nada.
Y no hay evidencia que diga, bueno, a demás de que las personas
simplemente no creen que las células hacen lo que hacen.
Así que, si las personas han caído en el pozo del dualismo metafísico,
algunas personas muy inteligentes, pero podemos rechazar todo eso.
(Risas)
No, no te voy a decir que hay algo mas,
y realmente es fundamental y esto es lo que es:
hay otra razón por la que no tenemos una buena teoría del cerebro,
y es porque tenemos una intuitiva, y fuerte,
pero incorrecta suposición que nos ha prevenido de ver la respuesta.
Hay algo que creemos que simplemente, es obvio, pero esta mal.
Hay una historia al respecto en la ciencia y antes que te diga cual es,
Te voy a contar un poco al respecto de la historia de ello en la ciencia.
Si observas otras revoluciones científicas,
y en este caso, estoy hablando del sistema solar, ése es Copernico,
La evolución de Darwin, las placas tectónicas, ése es Wegner.
Y todos tienen mucho en común con la ciencia cerebral.
Antes que nada, tenían muchos datos inexplicables. Muchos.
Pero se volvió mucho más manejable una vez que tuvieron una teoría.
Las mejores mentes estaban atoradas, personas muy, muy inteligentes.
No somos mas inteligentes hoy de lo que ellos eran en ese entonces.
Simplemente resulta que es muy difícil pensar en las cosas,
pero una vez que las has razonado, es fácil de entender.
Mis hijas entendieron estas tres teorías
en su marco de referencia básica para cuando estaban en el Jardín de Niños.
Y ahora no es tan difícil, aquí hay una manzana, aquí una naranja,
la tierra gira, y ese tipo de cosas.
Finalmente, otra cosa es que la respuesta siempre estuvo allí,
pero la ignoramos por ser obvia, y ese es el punto.
Era una creencia intuitiva que estaba incorrecta.
En el caso del Sistema Solar, la idea de que la tierra esta girando
y la superficie de la Tierra va como a mil kilómetros por hora,
y que la Tierra va por el Sistema Solar a un millón de kilómetros por hora.
Es una locura. Todos sabemos que la Tierra no se esta moviendo.
¿Tu sientes que te estas moviendo a miles de kilómetros por hora?
Por supuesto que no. Hubo alguien que dijo,
que estaba girando en el espacio y que es inmenso,
te encerrarían, y eso es lo que hacían en ese entonces.
(Risas)
Así que fue intuitivo y obvio. ¿Y que tal la evolución?
La evolución es lo mimo. Le enseñamos a nuestros hijos, pues, a Biblia dice,
que Dios creo a todas las especies, gatos son gatos, perros son perros,
personas son personas, plantas son plantas, no cambian.
Noé los puso en el Arca en ese orden, blah, blah, blah. Y tu sabes,
el hecho es que, si crees en la evolución, todos tenemos un ancestro en común,
y todo tenemos tenemos como ancestro común con la planta en la recepción.
Esto es lo que nos dice la evolución. Y es verdad. Es un poco increíble.
Y es lo mismo con las placas tectónicas
Todas las montañas y los continentes están como que flotando
encima de la Tierra. Esto como que no tiene sentido.
Así que ¿Cuál es la intuitiva pero incorrecta suposición,
que ha evitado que entendamos el cerebro?
Ahora te lo voy a decir, y va a parecer tan obvio que es correcto,
y ese el el punto, ¿No? Entonces voy a tener que hacer un argumento
de porque es incorrecta la otra suposición.
La cosa intuitiva pero obvia es que de alguna manera la inteligencia
es definida por el comportamiento,
que somos inteligentes por la manera en que hacemos las cosas
y la manera en que actuamos con inteligencia, y te voy a decir que eso esta mal.
Lo que es inteligencia esta definido por la predicción.
Y voy a llevarte a esto en unas pocas diapositivas,
darte un ejemplo de lo que esto significa. Aquí hay un sistema.
A los ingenieros les gusta ver a los sistemas de esta manera.
Dicen, bueno, tenemos esto en una caja y tenemos sus entradas y salidas.
Los de IA dicen, bueno la caja es una computadora programable
porque es el equivalente a un cerebro, le daremos entradas
y haremos que haga algo, tenga un comportamiento.
Y Alan Turing definió la prueba de Turing, que esencialmente dice,
sabremos que algo es inteligente si actúa idéntico a un humano,
Una métrica de comportamiento de lo que es la inteligencia es,
y esto se a pegado en nuestra mente por mucho tiempo.
Pero la realidad, yo le llamo inteligencia real.
La inteligencia real esta construida con algo mas.
Experimentamos el mundo por una secuencia de los patrones, y los almacenamos,
y los recordamos. Cuando los recordamos, los comparamos
contra la realidad, y estamos haciendo predicciones todo el tiempo.
Es una métrica eterna. Hay una métrica eterna cuando decimos,
¿Entendemos el mundo? ¿Estoy haciendo predicciones? Etc...
Todos están siendo inteligentes en este momento y no están haciendo nada.
Quizá te estés rascando, o escarbandote la nariz,
No lo se, pero no estas haciendo nada en este momento,
pero estas siendo inteligente, entiendes lo que estoy diciendo.
Porque eres inteligente y puedes hablar Español,
sabes cuál es la palabra al final de este -- (silencio)
enunciado.
La palabra te llego, y estas haciendo estas predicciones todo el tiempo.
Y luego, lo que esto diciendo es,
que esa eterna predicción es el resultado de la neo-corteza.
Y de alguna manera, la predicción nos lleva a comportamiento inteligente.
y así es que sucede. Empecemos con un cerebro sin inteligencia.
Bueno yo discuto un cerebro no inteligente, obtenemos un cerebro viejo,
y vamos a decir que no es de un mamífero, como un reptil,
así que diré, un lagarto, tenemos un lagarto.
Y el lagarto tiene unos sentidos muy sofisticados.
Tiene buenos ojos y oídos y sentido del tacto y así sucesivamente
una boca y una nariz. Y tiene un comportamiento muy complejo.
Puede correr y ocultarse. Tiene temores y emociones. Te puede comer, sabes.
Puede atacar. Puede hacer muchas cosas.
Pero no consideramos al lagarto muy inteligente, no como un humano al menos.
Pero ya tiene todo este comportamiento complejo.
Ahora, en la evolución, ¿Qué sucedió?
Lo primero que paso en la evolución con los mamiferos
es que empezamos a desarrollar la neo-corteza.
Y voy a representar a la neo-corteza aquí,
por esta caja que se encuentra encima del cerebro viejo.
Neo-corteza significa nueva capa. Es una nueva capa sobre tu cerebro.
Si no lo sabes es esa cosa arrugada en la parte superior de tu cabeza que,
se arrugo porque fue retacada ahí y no cabe.
(Risas)
No, en serio, es lo que es. Tiene el tamaño de una servilleta de mesa.
Y no cabe, asi que se arruga. Ahora ve lo que he dibujado, esto aquí.
El cerebro viejo sigue ahi. Aún tienes ese cerebro de lagarto.
Ahí esta. Es tu cerebro emocional.
Es todas esas cosas, y reacciones espontaneas que tienes.
Encima de ello, tenemos este sistema de memoria llamado la neo-corteza.
Y el sistema de memoria esta sobre la parte sensorial del cerebro.
Así que conforme entra la parte sensorial y alimenta desde el viejo cerebro,
También sube a la neo-corteza. Y la neo-corteza es simplemente memorización.
Esta ahí diciendo, ah, voy a memorizar todas las cosas que suceden,
dónde he estado, personas que he visto, cosas que he escuchado, así sucesivamente.
Y en el futuro, cuando ve algo similar a eso de nuevo,
en un ambiente similar, o el mismo ambiente,
lo reproduce. Empieza a reproducirlo.
Oh, ya he estado aquí antes. Y cuando he estado aquí antes,
esto sucedió después. Te permite predecir el futuro.
Te permite; literalmente retroalimenta las señales a tu cerebro,
te permiten ver qué es lo que sucederá después,
te permitirá escuchar la palabra enunciado aun antes que lo dijera.
Y es esta retroalimentación al cerebro viejo
que te permite tomar decisiones más inteligentes.
Ésta es la mas importante diapositiva de mi platica, así que haré hincapié en ella.
Así que, todo el tiempo dices, oh, puedo predecir cosas.
Y si eres una rata puedes recorrer un laberinto, y luego te lo puedes aprender,
la próxima vez que estés en el laberinto, tendrás el mismo comportamiento,
pero repentinamente, eres mas inteligente
porque dices, oh, reconozco este laberinto, y sé en que dirección ir,
He estado aquí antes, y puedo visualizar el futuro. Y eso es lo que está haciendo.
En humanos, por cierto, esto es verdad en todos los mamíferos,
esto es verdad para otros mamíferos, y en humanos, se puso peor.
En humanos, desarrollamos la parte frontal de la neo-corteza.
llamada la parte anterior de la neocorteza. Y la naturaleza hizo un pequeño truco.
Copió la parte posterior, la de atrás, que es sensorial,
y la puso en el frente
Los humanos tenemos de manera única el mismo mecanismo al frente,
pero o usamos para control motriz.
Así que ahora podemos hacer planeación motriz muy sofisticada, y cosas así.
No tengo tiempo de entrar en detalle, pero si quieres entender como funciona el cerebro,
tienes que entender cómo funciona la primera parte de la neo-corteza del mamífero,
cómo es que almacenamos patrones y hacemos predicciones.
Así que permítem dar algunos ejemplos de predicciones.
Ya dije la palabra enunciados. En música,
si has escuchado una canción antes, si escuchaste a Jill cantar esas canciones antes,
cuando las cante, la siguiente nota salta a nuestra cabeza de antemano --
lo anticipas conforme sigues adelante. Si fuese un álbum musical.
al final de una canción, la siguiente canción te llega a la mente.
Y estas cosas suceden todo el tiempo. Estás haciendo predicciones.
Yo tengo esta cosa llamada el experimento de la puerta alterada.
Y el experimento de la puerta alterada dice, tienes una puerta en casa,
y cuando estas aqui, yo estoy cambiándolo, tengo un señor
en tu casa en este momento moviendo la puerta,
y va a tomar la perilla y la moverá dos pulgadas.
Y cuando llegues a casa esta noche vas a extender tu mano,
y vas a extender tu mano hacia la perilla y vas a notar
que esta en el lugar equivocado, y dirás, oye, algo paso.
Puede que te tome un segundo averiguar que fue, pero algo paso.
Ahora podira cambiar tu puerta en otras maneras.
Puedo hacerla más grande o chica, puedo cambiarla de bronce a plata,
Puedo poner una palanca. Puedo cambiar tu puerta, ponerle colores,
Puedo ponerle ventanas. Puedo cambiar miles de cosas de tu puerta,
y en los dos segundos que te toma abrir tu puerta,
vas a notar que algo ha cambiado
Ahora, la manera ingenieril de aproximar esto, la manera IA de aproximarlo,
es construir una base de datos de puertas. Tiene todos los atributos de puertas.
Y conforme te acercas a la puerta,recorremos lista una por una.
Puerta, puerta, puerta, tu sabes, color, tu sabes lo que digo.
No hacemos eso. Tu cerebro no hace eso.
Lo que tu cerebro esta haciendo es predicciones constantes todo el tiempo
acerca de lo que va a pasar en tu ambiente.
Conforme pongo mi mano en esta mesa, espero sentir que se detenga.
Cuando camino, cada paso, si fallo por 5 milímetros,
Yo sabre que algo ha cambiado.
Estas constantemente haciendo predicciones acerca de tu entorno.
Hablaré brevemente acerca de la visión. Esta es la imagen de una mujer.
Y cuando ves a las personas, tus ojos están analizando
puntos de dos a 3 veces por segundo.
No estas consciente de eso, pero tus ojos siempre están en movimiento.
Así que cuando ves la cara de alguien,
comúnmente recorres de ojo a ojo a ojo a nariz a boca.
Ahora, cuando tus ojos se mueven de ojo a ojo,
si hubiera algo diferente ahí como una nariz,
verías una nariz donde se supone debe haber un ojo,
y dirías, mierda, tu sabes --
(Risas)
Hay algo mal con esta persona.
Y es porque estas haciendo una predicción.
No es como si vieras y dijeras, ¿Qué estoy viendo?
Una nariz, esta bien. No, tienes una expectativa de lo que vas a ver.
(Risas)
En cada momento. Y finalmente, pensemos acerca de cómo probamos la inteligencia.
La probamos por medio de la predicción. ¿Cuál es la siguiente palabra en este, tu sabes?
Esto es a esto como esto es a esto. ¿Cuál es el siguiente número en este enunciado?
Aquí hay tres vistas de un objeto.
¿Cuál es la cuarta? Así es como lo probamos. Se trata de predicciones.
Así que ¿Cuál es la receta para una teoría del cerebro?
Antes que nada, tenemos que tener el marco de referencia correcto.
Y el marco es un marco de memoria,
no un marco de comportamiento o cómputo. Es un marco de memoria.
¿Cómo almacenas y recuerdas estas secuencias o patrones? Son patrones espacio-temporales.
Entonces, si en ese marco, tomas un montón de teóricos.
Los biólogos por lo general no son buenos teóricos.
No siempre es verdad, pero en general, no hay buena historia de teoría en la biología.
Así que encontré que es mejor trabajar con físicos,
ingenieros y matemáticos, que tienden a pensar de manera algorítmica,
Entonces ellos tiene que aprender la anatomía y luego aprender la fisiología.
Tienes que hacer que estas teorías sean muy realistas en términos anatómicos.
Cualquiera que se pone de pie y te cuenta su teoría de como funciona el cerebro
y no te dice exactamente como funciona dentro del cerebro
y como funciona el cableado dentro del cerebro, no es una teoría.
Y eso es lo que estamos haciendo en el Instituto Redwood Neuroscience.
Me encantaría tener mas tiempo para contarte del avance fantástico que tenemos en ello,
y espero estar de regreso en este estrado,
quizá esto será en un futuro no muy lejano para que te cuente al respecto.
Estoy muy, muy emocionado. Esto no va a tomar 50 años.
Así que ¿Cómo será la teoría cerebral?
Antes que nada, tiene que ser una teoría respecto a la memoria.
No como la memoria de computadora. No es nada como la memoria de computadora.
Es muy distinta. Y es una memoria de estos
patrones dimensionales, como las cosas que vienen de tus ojos.
Es también memoria de secuencias.
No puedes aprender o recordar algo fuera de secuencia.
Una canción debe ser escuchada en secuencia en el tiempo,
y debes reproducirla en secuencia en el tiempo.
Y estas secuencias son recordadas auto-asociadas, así que si veo algo,
Escucho algo, me recuerda a ello, y se reproduce automáticamente.
Es una reproducción automática. La predicción del futuro gestiona el resultado deseado.
Y como dije, la teoría debe ser biológicamente acertada,
debe ser comprobable, y debes poderlo reconstruir.
Si no lo construyes, no lo entiendes. Así que una diapositiva mas aquí.
¿En qué va a resultar esto? ¿Realmente vamos a construir maquinas inteligentes?
Por supuesto. Y va a ser diferente de como creen las personas.
No hay duda alguna en mi mente de que va a suceder.
Antes que nada, va a escalarse, vamos a construirlo de silicio.
Las mismas técnicas que usamos para construir memorias de computadora de silicio,
las podemos usar para esto.
Pero son memorias muy distintas.
Y vamos a conectar esas memorias a sensores,
y a los sensores los expondremos a datos de la vida real,
y estas cosas van a aprender de su entorno.
Ahora es muy poco probable que las primeras cosas que veas sean como robots.
No que los robots no sean útiles y las personas pueden construir robots.
Pero la parte robótica es la parte más difícil. Es el cerebro antiguo. Eso es realmente difícil.
El nuevo cerebro es realmente más fácil que el cerebro viejo.
Así que lo primero que vamos a hacer son aquellas que no requieren mucha robótica.
Asi que no veras a C-3PO.
Verás cosas como autos inteligentes
que realmente entienden lo que es el tráfico y lo que es manejar
y han aprendido que cierto tipo de auto con la direccional encendida por medio minuto
probablemente no van a dar vuelta, cosas así.
(Risas)
También podemos hacer sistemas de seguridad inteligentes.
Donde sea que estemos usando nuestro cerebro, pero no haya mucha mecánica.
Éstas son las cosas que van a suceder primero.
Pero en última instancia, el mundo es nuestro limite.
No se como vaya a salir esto.
Conozco muchas personas que inventaron el microprocesador
y si hablas con ellos, sabían que lo que hacían era muy significativo,
pero ellos no sabían realmente lo que iba a pasar.
No podían anticipar celulares y el Internet y ese tipo de cosas.
Simplemente sabían que, oye, vamos a construir calculadoras
y controladores de semáforos. Pero va a ser grande.
De la misma manera, es como la ciencia del cerebro y estas memorias
van a ser una tecnologia fundamental, y nos va a llevar
a cambios increíbles en los próximos 100 años.
Y estoy muy emocionado de como vamos a usarlos en la ciencia.
Así que creo que es todo mi tiempo, ya me pase, voy a terminar mi platica
ahí mismo.